(musique dansante)
Samedi soir, à Donetsk.
alalcool coule à flot.
La musique est maître.
On se croirait dans n'importe
quel bar de Moscou, mais cette
joie de vivre, elle n'est
qu'éphémère. Les soirs
de week-end sont les seuls sans
couvre-feu ici, et bien sûr,
les gens en profitent.
Il suffit de les écouter pour
comprendre qu'on est vraiment
sur une autre planète.
"Nous vivons comme des otages
dit Tanya. Comme des apatrides
et personne ne sait vraiment ce
qui arrivera demain."
Est-ce qu'on sera en Ukraine
ou en Russie? Tout ce qu'on veut
c'est vivre en paix.
- La paix est une notion
bien ambiguë dans ce No Man's
land au r r r de l'Europe.
Une enclave isolée,
autoproclamée indépendante
de Kiev par les forces
séparatistes qui la contrôlent
avec le soutien indéniable
de Moscou, quoi qu'en dise
le Kremlin. Les couleurs dela R.
Ça fait des mois que notre
équipe attendait la permission
des rebelles pour entrer dans
cette zone de conflit absurde.
Svetlana Kissileva, photographe
- Autant le centre de Donetsk,
il est épargnée et la vie
a repris et le centre de Donetsk
ressembl n n n n'importe quelle
ville européenne, autant
la périphérie, il y a des gens
qui vivent constamment
en souffrance.
- Il faut bien connaître
le terrain pour s'aventurer hors
de la zone urbaine comme le fait
régulièrement Svetlana.
Elle est photographe qui est
revenue vivre dans son Donetsk
natal umumumumumenter
la guerre qui déchire son peuple
depuis 2014.
À seulement 10 kilomètres
du centre, c'est la désolation.
Les tirs sont fréquents et
s s s s surtout imprévisibles.
- "Zelensky je veux le déchirer
en morceaux", dit Rada.
En le regrettant presque
aussitôt parce qu'elle sait que
de l'autre côté, les enfants
souffrent autant que les siens.
Mais c'est plus fort qu'elle.
Sa fille est née en décembre
2014, au plus fort des combats,
ici dans la maison.
L'ambulance n'a pas pu venir
à cause des tirs, et c'est
son  papa qui a cododododododon.
- La guerre devait finir l'année
suivante, mais le cessez-le-feu
signé à Minsk est constamment
violé d'un côté comme de l'autre
dit Christelle, qui a choisi son
camp.
CHRISTELLE NEAN
- Les gens se trouvent
actuellement en danger parce que
les autoritéeseseseseseses
refusent de reconnaître
la volonté populaire qui s'est
exprimée en 2014.
- Elle est  une fermière qui
habite tout près de la ligne de
front de ce conflit qui
depuis 8 ans, a fait plus
14 000 morts.
- Donc si on n'applique pas
l'accord de paix, qu'est-ce
qu'il reste? Il ne reste que
la guerre.
- Comme beaucoup de gens ici,
je me suis fâchée avec mes amis,
et les membres de ma famille
parc o o o o o o o ont jamais
voulu voir la vérité telle
qu'elle est réellement.
- Ce qui est Svetlana,
Christelle et tant d'autres ici
une résistance légitime,
est considérée par l'Ukraine
une occupation illégale
par des terroristes armés
jusqu'aux dents par la Russie.
Une milice populaire
qui est sous-dirigée par
Eduard Basurin qui a reçu
Radio-Canada pour une rare
entrevue dans son quartier
général.
Il pointe sur la carte
les zones où il accuse
l'armée ukrainienne de préparer
n n n n n n n n n majeure
et  imminente.
Il dit que  les forces
ukrainiennes de l'autre côté
sont gavées d'armes
comme jamais, gracieuseté des
pays de l'OTAN. Mais il nie
avoir dans ses rangs
russe ou des mercenaires.
Et quand nous avons demandé
d'aller voir les soldats
au front, la réponse a été non.
- Rada ne sait plus qui croire.
Sa seule certitude, c'est que
l'enfance de sa fille est
foutue. À huit ans, Sveta sait
lire et eeeeeeeeee
aujourd'hui, elle ne sort que
pour aller à l'école et même
en classe, c'est dangereux.
La banalisation de l'anormal est
bouleversante chez les enfants.
Et pour les retraités
comme Victor, c'est une fin
de vie insoutenable.
Il y a à peine une semaine,
sa maison a encore été frappée.
Victor y a échappé b
Outre la Russie qui distribue
des passeports, il n'y aucune
autre porte de sortie.
"Et ce que je vais vous dire
n'est pas un secret,
dit-il, la République de Donetsk
ne pourra jamais survivreseule."
- Les histoires d'invasion russe
de l'Ukraine, comme les médias
américains, nous l'ont serviodo,
c'est du grand n'importe quoi.
Si vous demandez aux gens d'ici
"Où est l'armée russe?",
les gens vous diront en rigola
que ça fait 8 ans qu'ils les
attendent et qu'ils lest t t t d
plaisir.
Et dans l'adversité,
devant l'inconnu...
(musique de Tchaïkovsky)
...Vadim Pisarev , qui était
des plus grands danseurs de
ballet de l'Ukraine brandit
son art comme un drapeau blanc.
Il dirige le théâtre de Donetsk
depuis bien avant la guerre,
mais il a décié
et offre des billets gratuits
aux plus éprouvés.
Cette paix qui n'arrive pas
et qui ne dépend plus d'eux.